yozone c'est ce que je veux dire surtout
sur le web en courtage et dans lequel on
construit son robot pour aller péter les
fesses d'autres joueurs dont cajanek de
construire mon robot ceci est absolument
faux au servage lance julien rohbock et
préconstruits on dit merci merci les
devs c'est gentil coup j'ai absolument
rien débloqué mais j'ai quand même
quelques trucs par défaut comme cette
tourelle voilà on va mettre juste là je
propose qu'on allait tester notre robot
en ligne on va se faire défaut je suis
rassuré quand je vois sa petite
mobylette est lui là bas mais je crois
que tous les nouveaux sur ce jour la
même stratégie c'est mettre le plus de
tours elle possible sur son véhicule
regarde va suivre cookie monster parce
qu'ils aiment ceux de génial en
médiatrice à ce pas être là au bon dieu
il va décéder direct et en plat il a
pété mon garde la défoncer et m'a cassé
deux tourelles le mais c'est pas grave
on s'en fout il nous en reste quatre mon
gars en fait c'est une heure de
domination quoi nous le voyons nos
styles font hélas péter il a pété le
début et tout est grâce à moi vraiment
ils font quoi ils copient l'on peut
copuler aussi ah non oui ben compilé
manière forte même et on a gagné à ok
faut que je débloque d'autres apps dans
un arbre de talent qui fait 6000 km urd
est ce qu'on peut avant bord des fusils
d'assaut des ak-47 accroché au véhicule
regardez ce mec il a carrément satellite
sur son véhicule il capte les chaînes il
capte la tnt l'enfoiré haye follow your
way braille est avant ce [ __ ] mais on
fait du drift [ __ ] il aussi nul que
moi ce mec comme ça soit il a le même
véhicule nul d'ailleurs à hausse à aulas
l'âge j'ai pété un câble on a trouvé une
petite route dans les attaques de louise
attaque dollars ça marche on regarde et
on est même allé mais mal
ils sont trois et excalibur voilà comme
ça on s'est enflammée du coût du travail
oit bien ta tuque ou écrire dessus
olala j'étais une cible gratuite quoi
regarder il est arrivé la même chose que
moi je pense que le mieux c'est de faire
un tout petit véhicule en fait tu vas
faire un truc 2 0 voilà y'a plus rien on
va juste y aller avec cette tourelle
oui monsieur c'est beau voilà on part
sur un panneau solaire qui va alimenter
donc le véhicule c'est totalement faux
mais j'aime bien faire sur moi tu me
connais beaucoup et c'est pas mal du
tout de quoi faire gagner en iran petit
scorpion avec sa grande que comme ça
ouais c'est quoi ce qu'il a fait mon
gars il a fait juste une grosse ligne de
cube avec le plus de tours est possible
[ __ ] il est plus fort que nous je veux
voir ça de plus près sans déconner mais
ils pouvaient pas se déplacer ils
avaient promis drop la paix juste mais
un siège et pourrait lui coller à bien
d'autres mais qui va regarder ça de plus
près ce mec bouassa la nasa c'est sûr
regardé aa à se moquer comme des [ __ ]
c'est parti fini de se moquer d'un
camarade au but ça se passe pas très
mature dans le bac les gars dans le bac
à tamaghza un vrai beau fixe cuves cos
rien du tout
oui ils pensent tous pouvoir nous
échapper mais non monsieur o te poursuis
ton [ __ ] c'est la battle c'est battles
et la bataille fait mal vite forgé des
tourelles il respire un affectueux et
respectons la dernière tourelles howe
est emmerdé respire hier tu avais le
bordel à puis on peut la voir
oh non non mais il est pas des guides
véhicule quand même on a gagné à enlever
un bon envol y avait un peu d'air qui
nous aider mes choix là j'ai un peu plus
protégé le pilote beaucoup y voient plus
rien on s'en fout le scorpion et dans
l'impact et non c'est pas le moment
non c'est pas loin après compression
faiblesse extrême c'est le vrai moment
il faut il faut améliorer ça je teste un
truc pour protéger les revoilà nos
routes
je pense que le truc est cent fois trop
lourd et voilà writers gotta fight parce
qu'on est latent ok on va le tenter
celui-là ça un vrai tank
bon on roule sans problème non mais
franchement on a fait un super véhicule
un oh [ __ ] mais je me shoote annoncé
qu'arnaud pas stable ok on se déplace
comme ça hayoun a bloqué mais non mais
on est des losers [ __ ] notre but dans
la gueule c'est pas tu as un mec s'est
passé pour owen mathieu selwa on verra
regardez regardez tout ce qu il fait du
ski y'a plus rien sur son véhicule garé
à des mecs ils étaient là sauf son siège
à glisser sur la neige non tu meurs
suivant bordel alors au nom ça va ou
quoi attendez on a on est en train de
mettre la vie cela allez à bientôt honte
a explosé et on lui met un petit est
chaude du hms victory on est quatrièmes
de la guerre mon écran le progrès voilà
on a rajouté d'euros pour plus de
stabilité et paris ou de collages aux
helvètes s'ingénie à côté quand on voit
notre truc dont on est beaucoup moins
des génies d'un coup un allez salut à
bientôt au les faut on leur a fait une
embuscade c'était fatal je te suis mon
gars allez allez non mais à
on est en train de capturer l'objectif
bon bah on a gagné
ouais on a tous compris pourquoi je sens
je sens que en voilà exactement comme ça
je m'en allais web maintenant 20 h mon
cher à cherbourg à willebroek neige ont
fait une double protection derrière nous
dès renoue les gares les quais étaient
juste là
non ils étaient juste là j'ai rien
compris la bonne nouvelle c'est que homo
il ya plus beau noël finalement quitté
cette idée celle des liens on laisse pas
on laisse pas bien joué les envahit les
enfants aïe aïe peut nommer le mont houy
tulipes en regardant mon petit crâne et
a découvert que me rendre utile jusqu'à
la dernière seconde les gars je suis
dans le boudin et grandes écoles je me
déplace vous sentez un peu la détresse
de l'homme a on a trouvé pire que nous
entend lui avait 120 milles rouen et on
a perdu
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut
améliorer notre tour m
c'est parti [ __ ] les lumières et où
elle est une lumière mais l'appel permis
par comptons dépensons des pour
jean-michel pas tant qu il a fait sa
grossesse
ouais ben va rejoindre une autre partie
parce que vous étiez nul orienter le lui
même et y en a qui sont des équipes mais
c'est vraiment la stratégie du jeu veut
mettre un max de tourelle en lega les
gars pourquoi je suis aller devant
pourquoi j'ai fait le mec koudou qui va
devant elle on y va on y va on y va les
gars aïe
saloperie nomix cube on n'a pas le temps
on n'a pas le temps à les véhicules de
merde là tu dis que la guerre puis là je
suis là cela ne fut pas ne fut pas
devant le danger
bon tu es décédé au c'est quoi ça non
non c'est quoi ce truc
regardez ce congrès est le véhicule le
plus original du monde
la ligne de la mort et qu'on dit
aujourd'hui par ce pilote pas du tout
protégé c'est nul à chier comme véhicule
je n'arrive pas à jouer c'est nul c'est
tu le sais nul archi nul il perdu
l'hyper u non self destruct sans aucun
remord il a lancé un missile
ce mec est un lance-missile quoi
calmement et franc sur le côté comme ça
ni vu ni connu
pourquoi attends je me suis pris au
moins 2001 je me suis pris c'est quoi sa
nouvelle mais qu'il a un canot qui fait
moins douze mille quoi protéger un canon
il fait moins 12 villes mettent pas le
même que le tient qu'à moi et petit-fils
est elles font moins 100 dois je le
rappeler mais c'est scandaleux
quel est le fuck sans déconner c'est
quoi cet homme tu nous a sorti là c'est
quoi c'est ça la sema launcher dommage
1500 allez salut et année c'est un peu
comme ça qu'ils avaient comme but la
cahc 3,36 s'il a juste mais non on va
regarder des quatre chemins en blanc qui
l'empêchent de jouer empêcher l'autre
joué bloqué neuf je te plante les gars
alors lui avec son temps que là et c'est
légal c'est légal ça dégage la la boîte
de conserve la à temps il va me tuer le
con mais moi cependant je viens de
comprendre le but du jeu il faut juste
avec capture et la base ennemie avant
que les ennemis capture notre basano
voilà et là apparemment on a perdu
voilà vous voyez que j'ai donc très bien
compris ça va le blaireau qui glisse
nous sommes des gens nuls en ont après
le pont la glace qui tue à faire moi
j'escalade mon gars bien sûr je fais
plein de fois la montagne
voilà mais se trouve phare ces gens
allaient lui le défaussement gars on lui
fait péter la cervelle on lui fait péter
la cervelle
oh non mais si oui c'est de la blague
oui bon les gens qui gèrent fois de
cette zone sur robot kraft j'espère si
vous a plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
venir et vidéo comme d'habitude et on
peut constater que nous sommes
extrêmement nu dans la construction de
vaisseaux ont malheureusement ça a l'air
d'être un peu un pay to win et android
tu peux acheter pour certaines sommes
des gros vaisseaux déjà fait avec des
mitraillettes hyper évoluer voie qu'il
faut par exemple du moins 1500 mah on a
pu le voir très agréable de se prendre
pour 1500 derrière moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé mais je trouvais qu'il était sympa
de construire son vaisseau but de le
tester sur champ de bataille contre
d'autres joueurs qui ont eux-mêmes
construit leur vaisseau avant ma façon
de retrouver dans une nouvelle vidéo
merci avoir regardé tout au moins avec
les deux doigts tout lourd ps3 à l'e3
hockey
on continue au oui il est tombé ou
l'abus des skis que j'étais fort les
permis ont selon keller veut passer